F
OU SAW IT  ON THE OTHENJOIWHASR
GOING TO HEAD UP THO
SO HE WHEN
WHENTAKES THE  HE'OI
GONSRENC E'S GOING
I DON'T OW
BU AT THATOIAS
AT THAT POIN IIM TEED TO PROTEE
MEAN,
HOALL,HE
DOO GO HI
THEY'D BE IERE
NSIDE OF M, WHAT'S ALLABT? HE H.
WE KNOW THA T INFECTION,
C
TAKE PAINSTHEMSEHOSPITIS -- IT .
>>ERYIF OFF.
CORRECTES AIMFF AND HE'S
PICTUR FLANK HIM.ITN? H
THIS IS W HE IMAGEO
STRONG, THISUS I
FEELING
20 YEAR
FCO I
WE NRESIDESTEROIDS ARUG THATEWF
CLINICALS HAV GDE THE UNITED STA
HE H LEVELFATNTEL O C M
UN PTHT
SL ET.
THAT ERY IS FIN HEAIET
RO VERY  THE A
AND THE ED ENTRANCE THAT IDT  H
STILL HASRONAVIRUS.
HE'SY
LOT OF INFORMATION A HHE
SAY THATELIEFNTMONDAY.
THAT'S AEEK FROM
WEEK
IN
-
HE'SNG E. T
IAO
THE
SANJE
O
RIGH
APEOPLERE IN THE  HE - I
KW, LIKEL
IDUESIDE,LT
OUTSIDE.EOMO
O T
ERE
ET
O
ERE T H
VIS.NOW HE COE S
TH OUGE CONCER
AND KAITHE
MEDICATIONSAIN.HING A
WELL, HE LEA TTOOKS.
T YKN W
WI TMECAPECIAL  S  M IT GIVEY. .
CONCAGAIN, THE DOC ATER
MNYINON.OC THIS.SNSWAY THAT I RT
GHEEVET AND PERHAPS THE OFGATIV,
OR  THERE IS
THM THNS
CATH GRG WASHIN SITY HTAISED M O
CHENEY AND HEAUES
EMERGENCY PHIC M FA
WITH YOHOSPAL AND ISNG NPAENPHT
RE
SOMETHINUTTH E DEAREAES
OPTER
ENTRANCE AND T
ASE A YS EXPECTI HOLHET
'S
PRD STAT AIVVIRUS, MIIORTLE
TTGEMOUS NUMBE
THATSKEDG VERBUILDIEALLY UND N O
S IS T
RADAYS.EBE ANY CHARGAN
UTE T HOW MUCH OF HIS
A
PATIENT, HOW MUCHFIZATIO TRG BYT
>>ANTO - I
JUST AEC
KEEP. H
HENAING  A THI
E OH, IOW.
HISASBVIOUSLYLL
AN S A WE HAVE OF HAS H'L JUST .
FAUST, WHEN POINT, BECAU IT'S IM
IEARSO,FR COVIITHDEMEHEAR?
>>WEON
ORHE S LGH HE S FLY
IT.T AT  ES ORURING BATE WITH
SOE' PUTTING-
KNOWE'TI  RISK.
FROM THE VIEWPOINT OF
CORONAVIRUS,HICH DSN SEUTNK
AROUOT A
ONEOEFRKTS TSTOF THE'S UNBELIEV
A
.O RCEND
E  SYT, DON'T LET
YON
TCADTCWAS --E BAD
YETER R
FTE NOHERE.
WETME,COS
>> AND
, H ORY
.
TH THE SH
>>YEAH,GRAPHER W
N
PROGRAM, YE  AGAIN I
PHOTOGRAPH
BUT T PRESI I WHO
TRO HSTOMATI HE HAS -- WE
THECONA SULECAUSE EVERYONEAS
ATIC AEADLYEAAT IS VER CONTS EC
SITUATIO
AIN, SEE HIM INHE
NDALIS IS PRETTRECKLESS.
SOM PSSURD.SON WITH KNOWN C
DEHO AK ON
IS W INTO THEDE ARE AROU
MAY'RE MASKS T
BUT HLRHE DI AREA WILL NEED AMA,